not all lawyers are good I cannot
emphasize this enough and not all
lawsuits are well stated that is doubly
true and while you have a constitutional
right to a jury trial I have a First
Amendment right to make fun of you
mercilessly in front of millions of
subscribers
now In fairness frivolous lawsuits are
often brought by self-represented
individuals who are unable to find a
lawyer to take their crazy cases but
sometimes there are actual attorneys who
are willing to attach their names and
reputations to the lawsuits that we're
going to destroy today so let's start
with the case of the candy box that has
too much air in it a time-honored
tradition of going to the movies is
buying movie candy and one of the more
popular movie candies for inexplicable
reasons is Junior Mints the candy that
tastes like you just went to the
dentist's office now if you've ever
picked up a box of Junior Mints you
might have noticed that the box is not
exactly filled to the top with candy for
many this is an irritating example of
shrinkflation where companies downsize
the size or quantity of the product that
you receive while charging the same
amount of money and if you've ever gone
to a movie theater you're being charged
way way too much for basically mint
flavored wax but for New York City
resident Biola Daniel The Heir in the
junior mince package was an egregious
fraud perpetrator upon the American
public and for that Injustice Miss
Daniel and her lawyers decided to take
his stand for consumers everywhere so in
2017 Miss Daniel filed a class action
lawsuit against Tootsie Roll Industries
the parent company of Junior Mints
claiming the manufacturer intentionally
tricks customers by packaging their
candies in unexpectedly large boxes
topped with too much air referred to in
the complaint as slack film so as I move
this up and down it's going to pump air
out of the jar Abel during of New York
and traquila Perkins of Mississippi
would later join the lawsuit as class
plaintiffs according to the 36-page
complaint Miss Daniel purchased a 3.5
ounce box of Junior Mints from a local
pharmacy for 1.49 Miss Daniel complained
that the Box quote contained
approximately 40 percent non-functional
slack fill while competitor candies like
Milk Duds and Good and Plenty only
contain 23 and 12 slack fill
respectively in addition to those
candies actually being something a human
should consume the complaint said quote
the size of the products boxes in
comparison to the volume of the candy
contained therein makes it appear to
Plaintiff and class members that they
are buying more than what is actually
being sold plaintiff and class members
are denied the benefit of their bargain
because they pay for a full box of the
product but actually received far less
but U.S District Judge Naomi Reese
buckwald disagreed tossing the complaint
10 months later in her 44-page ruling
dripping with shade judge buckwal
determined that there was no fraud in
junior men's packaging and ripped the
plaintiffs for claiming that they had
been intentionally deceived by slackfill
the judge argued that there was no
deception because reasonable consumers
of ordinary intelligence could have
determined the amount of the candies
from reading the Box quote the law
simply does not provide the level of
coddling the plaintiff's Sikh assuming
that a reasonable consumer might ignore
the evidence plainly before him
attributes to Consumers a level of
stupidity that the court cannot
countenance and according to Reuters
hundreds of slackfill lawsuits have been
filed in recent years and in the last
decade alone Tootsie Roll LLC has faced
five separate lawsuits over air in its
candy boxes with judges in California
New York Illinois and New Jersey all
dismissing these cases now to be fair to
the class plaintiffs here it's not
impossible to win these lawsuits
according to the FDA a container that
does not allow the consumer to fully
view its content shall be considered to
be filled as to be misleading if it
contains non-functional slack fill
slackfill is the difference between the
actual capacity of the container and the
volume of product contained they're in
and the slack fill is non-functional if
it is filled to less than capacity for
reasons other than one the protection of
the contents of the package to the
requirements of the machines used for
enclosing the contents in such package
three unavoidable products settling
during shipping and handling for the
need for the package to perform a
specific function five the fact that the
product consists of a food packaged in a
reusable container or six the inability
to increase level of fill or to further
reduce the size of the package but under
these circumstances it looks like these
judges have determined that slack fill
lawsuits are full of hot air
get it am I right
okay fine boo me for my amazing puns I
can hear you through the computer but
that takes us to the Minnesota magician
who sued David Copperfield and David
Blaine for stealing his Godly powers
now you've probably heard that the oft
repeated Axiom that people who choose to
represent themselves in court well you
know they have a fool for a client but
enter Christopher roller a Minnesota
magician who decided that he would also
be that fool by repeatedly suing famous
magician David Copperfield for millions
of dollars on what grounds you may ask
why for stealing rollers god-like
magician powers without just
compensation obviously Now The Saga
began in March of 2005. when roller sued
David Copperfield in Minnesota federal
court quote David Copperfield has been
using my Godly powers to perform his
magic the complaint begins before
directing the court to his website so it
may witness Roller's quote journey to
Godliness citing UFO videos as proof
that Godly Powers exist on Earth roller
argues that magicians including
Copperfield quote have also been granted
Godly Powers by me some somehow but they
have been keeping it a secret and
keeping the credits from me
roller who claims he's been secretly
filmed for decades all of The Truman
Show good afternoon good evening and
good night is an avid conspiracy
theorist uh if you didn't guess that
already with a history of filing bizarre
frivolous lawsuits like in 2007 when he
sued then President George W bush and
Vice President Dick Cheney for
conspiring with quote fellow demons to
have roller murdered with an explosive
device at a Red Lobster in Roller's
complaint he graciously gives
Copperfield a way out of the litigation
to reveal his magician's secrets that
prove copperfield's tricks Illusions are
done conventionally and without Godly
Powers but roller lamented that t has
quote politely asked David via email to
show how his tricks are done with no
response I guess Mr Copperfield just
doesn't have time for rollers tricks I
don't have time for your magic tricks
illusion stand you don't have time for
my illusion that roller who has never
worked for Copperfield in any capacity
City claimed the magician had violated
Minnesota labor law by stealing his
magic thus entirely roller to a modest
50 million dollars 10 percent of all
past future career earnings and in 2016
Minnesota Court summarily dismissed
Roller's case for failure to State a
claim but believe it or not rollers Saga
against David Copperfield actually gets
weirder in June of 2005 roller attempted
to patent his magic powers in his patent
application roller refers to himself as
a quote Godly entity who seeks the
exclusive right to the ethical use and
financial gain in the use of Godly
powers on planet Earth roller then sued
David Copperfield again in federal court
this time for patent infringement and
while emotions who dismiss the case was
pending roller filed an amended
complaint alleging the Copperfield and
at least three other defendants were
engaged in a conspiracy to murder him so
in November 2007 the federal court again
dismissed Roller's claim with prejudice
and barred the vexatious litigant from
from ever suing Copperfield again and
here's a pro tip
even if you had Godly powers that would
not entitle you to a patent on those
Godly Powers which by the way would
expire after 17 years so you know I I'm
getting that this guy has not put
everything together but the court
dismissed the patent fringement claim on
the grounds that the patent actually had
not been granted and thus roller had no
patent rights that could be infringed
the court also found that there were
zero facts to support the claim that
Copperfield was involved in a murderous
conspiracy against roller and to add
insult to injury in 2008 the U.S patent
and trademark office rejected Roller's
patent writing quote the specification
has not described how one of ordinary
skill in the art could make or use the
acclaimed Godly powers and in a near
identical lawsuit filed in June 2005
roller sued magician David Blaine for
two million dollars accusing the
Magician of stealing Roller's Godly
powers to perform his magic are you sure
you didn't buy a teddy bear yes I'm sure
I didn't yeah teddy bear what the f how
did you but the court dismissed that
lawsuit as well due to Roller's failure
to serve Mr Blaine with the complaint
and that's the thing about trying to sue
a magician they'll just disappear on you
takes us to the lawsuit of the Oregon
man who filed a billion dollar lawsuit
because Michael Jordan sort of kind of
maybe looks like him now as you probably
know few people have embodied the
greatness of sports like basketball
Superstar and popular meme template
Michael Jordan as the iconic basketball
player who earned six championship rings
with the Chicago Bulls and nabbed a
starting role in the critically
unclaimed Space Jam many have credited
uh MJ as the true goat of the NBA it's
just funny because I don't remember
Jordan winning championships
with two different teams
iconic 90s Gatorade commercials not
everyone wanted to be like Mike
especially not Portland Oregon resident
Alan Heckard who claimed that his life
had been completely ruined after being
mistaken for the basketball champion
nearly every day for 15 years and argued
to an actual court of law that Michael
Jordan and Nike owed him nearly 1
billion dollars for his horrific
Injustice
because America in 2006 Heckard sued
Michael Jordan for 416 million dollars
arguing that the Space Jam star was
liable to Hecker for emotional pain and
suffering defamation and permanent
injury Heckard acting as his own
attorney I probably don't need to tell
you allege the following in the
complaint quote whatever public
functions he attends people are
continually on a daily basis harassing
him of looking like Michael Jordan these
unpleasant feelings from the public have
trouble heckard's nerves and denied him
the right to a peace of mind uh hashtag
you have no legal right to that peace of
mind now Heckard also sued Nike founder
Phil knightfur 416 million as well
writing in the complaint that night
quote contributed to Turning Michael
Jordan into a legend which forced
Heckard to change his appearance in
interviews Heckard asserted the
resemblance to Michael Jordan was so
powerful that he would frequently draw
crowds of disappointed Jordan fans
whenever he went to church or played
basketball in the park quote it's making
life uncomfortable I'm constantly being
harassed I should be able to enjoy my
own life but everywhere I go people tell
me I look exactly like him now Heckard
arguably Bears some resemblance to MJ
with a shaved head and earring on his
left ear and similar conditioning from
playing Amateur Basketball but
it should also be noted that the 51 year
old shuttle bus driver is eight years
older than Michael Jordan and at six
feet tall stands a full six inches
shorter than the six-time NBA champion
and in this lawyer's opinion the
gentleman from Portland should be
flattered that anyone should mistake him
for Michael friggin Jordan on the
basketball court but Hecker did not find
the comparison complimentary at all now
when asked how he arrived at the damages
amount of 416 million Heckard told the
media quote well you figure with my age
and you multiply that times seven and uh
then I turn around and I figure that's
what it all boils down to uh yeah so
that's not how calculating damages Works
uh or for that matter math but you don't
need a law degree to understand why no
lawyer agreed to take such a patently
frivolous defamation case to assert a
claim for defamation a plaintiff has to
show that the defendant made a false
statement a fact about the plaintiff to
a third party and his false statement
caused harm to the plaintiff now I
probably don't need to tell you that
being repeatedly confused for celebrity
does not come close to being defamatory
especially when there's no evidence
anyone did anything to propagate the
falsehood and it's not even a falsehood
it's like when people say that I look
like Ryan Reynolds or John Krasinski
that's whatever the opposite of
defamation is now when people say I look
like a Disney character or a dad from a
Pixar movie that is defamation I don't
know where this disrespectful attitude
came from but Hecker doesn't allege that
Michael Jordan or Nike falsely claimed
that Heckard is Michael Jordan so this
is not defamation the complaint much
like Packers damages calculation is
essentially just the Underpants Gnomes
of lawsuits false one collect Underpants
false two
fell through profit and I get it now
Weeks Later Heckard would spare the
legal system and further Drama by
withdrawing the lawsuit without
explanation but the explanation is it
was a frivolous lawsuit but that takes
us to the firefighter who was afraid to
enter burning buildings for fear of fire
now when pollsters ask people to name
the most trusted and admired professions
you'll often find firefighters at the
top of the list perhaps it's because
they're like police but they don't have
a gun with which to kill you but who
doesn't love firefighters when they
aren't saving cats from trees or posing
for hunky calendars firefighters are
famous for charging into burning
buildings to rescue those In Harm's Way
but one Texas firefighter tried to claim
that his fear of charging into burning
buildings was equivalent to a legal
disability and his removal from the
front lines was illegal disability
discrimination a spoiler he lost enter
Shane proller a captain of the Houston
fire department leader of a fire
suppression crew who had one teeny tiny
problem he was afraid of fire for
example in 2004 Pro arrived at the scene
of a fire and was unable to enter the
building in 2006 during a house fire
Prowler was so frightened that he was
unable to put on his firefighting gear
take orders or even walk properly a
doctor determined polar experienced a
temporary memory loss called Global
transient Amnesia the city then
reassigned polar to firefighting
Training Academy Prolo responded by
filing a successful administrative
appeal after which he was returned to
the fire suppression crew and when the
city took it to trial proer filed a
counterclaim arguing that his
reassignment violated laws against
disability discrimination Prowler did
not claim he was disabled just the city
of Houston perceived him to be disabled
making his reassignment a violation of
state and federal anti-discrimination
laws the jury agreed awarding prohllar
362 thousand dollars in Damages the case
was appealed all the way to the Texas
Supreme Court which throughout the jury
verdict in the Supreme Court's opinion
the court highlighted that
anti-disibility laws didn't not protect
every person who wants a job but who
lacks the mental physical or
experiential skill to perform that
particular job to illustrate the point
the court argued that lacking the skills
to play for the San Antonio Spurs does
not mean a person is disabled
accordingly the court concluded that
there was not a scintilla of evidence
that the fearful fire captain was
disabled prolar then argued that even if
he was not disabled the city perceived
him as such and thus is liable for
taking an adverse employment action
namely by reassigning him based on the
perceived disability the court rejected
this argument that there was no basis
for classifying prowler's fear as a
disability a disability was defined as
being regarded as having a mental or
physical impairment that substantially
limits at least one major life activity
and major life activity refers to basic
functions uh like taking care of
yourself walking seeing thinking and
breathing now under these definitions
the Court held that there was no
disability discrimination against the
fearful fireman because quote finding
fires is not a major life activity the
court also found that prowler's fear of
entering burning buildings was not a
disability to be discriminated against
noting quote a reluctance to charge into
a burning building is not a mental
impairment at all it's the normal human
response such a reluctance cannot be
characterized as an impairment much less
an impairment that substantially limits
a major life activity but if you're
bitter over that lawsuit that's nothing
compared to the bitterness that a
certain Austin resident felt for a date
who texted during a movie and for whom
he sued for 17.31 cents now when it
comes to finding love there's nothing
more exhilarating and nerve-wracking
than the first date the excitement and
promise of a lasting connection tempered
by The Dread this will end in
disappointment like all others or
and in a lawsuit against you for texting
but that's exactly what happened when
Brandon WesMer turned a dispute over a
date texting during a movie into a legal
dispute by suing her for 17.31 cents the
cost of the movie here's what happened
in May of 2017 37 year old vesmer took a
35 year old woman who I'm just going to
call uh Nola exit to see Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 2 in 3D in Austin Texas
everything was going fine until this
exit began to text the way the vesmer
put it quote it was kind of a first date
from hell this is like one of my biggest
pet peeves yes I'm sure that it was just
horrible for him and this poor woman was
having the time of her life and was
being completely inconsiderate now after
suggesting that Miss exit step outside
detects when she refused to stop uh she
then left the theater and never came
back leaving vesmer to find his own ride
because yeah that checks out now
according to text messages posted on his
now defunct Twitter account the esmer
demanded that she pays 17 for the movie
ticket and four dollars for the slice of
pizza that he bought her or else he
would take her to small claims court
Miss exit likely assumed that this was
an empty threat I mean who would haul
someone into small claims court over a
bogus 20 claim but apparently that
person was none other than her date
brand investment in his petition vesmer
alleged the Miss exit used her phone to
read and send text messages at least 10
to 20 times in 15 minutes in direct
violation of the theater's policy
adversely affecting the viewing
experience of plaintiff and others
vesmer asked the court for 17.31 cents
in compensation for defendant movie
ticket dropping his initial four dollar
demand for the pizza he closed his
petition in dramatic fashion writing
quote well damages sought are modest to
the principle is important as
defendant's behavior is a threat to
civilized society
so
you can save civilized society for 17.31
cents
that's kind of a bargain when you put it
that way now the story immediately went
viral with the AV club calling him a
hero and Guardians director James Gunn
cheekily suggesting that vesmer's date
deserved jail time but not everyone was
cheering let's go Brandon especially the
poor woman who went on this date when
the Austin American statesman informed
her about the lawsuit she replied oh my
God this is crazy she then disputed
vesmer's claim that she texted 10 to 15
times saying she only sent two texts to
a friend uh in a fight with her
boyfriend and kept her phone low to
ensure no one was Disturbed she then
issued a statement to a local news
station quote I did have a very brief
date with Brandon that I chose to end
prematurely his behavior made me
extremely uncomfortable and I felt I
needed to remove myself from the
situation for my own safety he has
escalated the situation far past what
any mentally healthy person would I feel
sorry that I hurt his feelings badly
enough that he felt he needed to commit
so much time and effort into seeking
Revenge I hope one day he can move past
this and find peace in his life yeah why
am I not surprised that this guy
completely misread the situation uh I
guess it might have been a tip-off that
he filed a lawsuit that had no legal
Merit whatsoever purely out of spite I
guess that yeah that probably should
have tipped me off to that now this
matter was finally settled in a sense
thanks to Inside Edition who arranged
for the pair to meet outside the
original movie theater because you know
that worked the first time she ended up
paying this guy 17.31 cents telling him
quote the date just didn't work out just
leave this alone and while vesmer did
drop the suit he stands by his conduct
count it right just to make sure it's
all here 10 15 16 17 31 cents and vesmer
issued a statement that he wanted people
to quote treat other people with respect
and dignity exactly the kind of respect
and dignity that is not commensurate
with filing a [ __ ] lawsuit out of
Revenge sorry Brandon it's settled
now if you'd like to see even more dumb
criminals and terrible lawyers check out
my new exclusive video too hot for
YouTube but I'm sorry to tell you it's
too hot for YouTube so to see that
exclusive video you'll have to head over
to today's sponsors nebula and curiosity
stream because on nebula my videos
always come out early with zero ads and
I release exclusive content all the time
like an entire video about legal stories
that are not safe for work and too hot
for YouTube as well as exclusive videos
like things people misunderstand about
the Constitution why nfts are bad for
creators and my first full-length
documentary bad law words good and tons
more all exclusive to nebula and all
this exclusive content is available only
on nebula which you get for free with
curiosity stream because nebula is
Creator owned and Creator operated
there's new exclusive content released
multiple times every day and by the way
we've been developing nebula like crazy
nebula now has apps for iOS Android
Apple TV Roku Fire TV and Android TV and
it was recently nominated for its first
streamy award my fellow creators and I
really care about nebula and we're
thrilled to be partnering with curiosity
stream because they're the go-to source
for the best documentaries and long-form
educational content on the internet and
they even have an entire section devoted
to Unsolved Mysteries and crimes so if
you like my videos you'll love the
thousands of titles on curiosity stream
now the best way to get access to nebula
and all this incredible content is
through the amazing curiosity stream
nebula bundle deal with his current
sales price of less than 15 per year to
get full access to both sites and to be
clear that nebula's subscriptions on
trial it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member there just isn't
a better deal in streaming where you get
access to two great streaming sites with
content that you'll actually watch and
enjoy all for less than fifteen dollars
per year at the current sales price so
sign up now by clicking on the button
that's on screen right now or you can
click on the link that's down below in
the description it's a great way to
support educational content and get tons
of exclusive content that you'll love so
click on the link below right now and
after that click on this playlist over
here for more legal eagle or I'll see
you in court